dann auch bei unserer talksendung bei
viertel nach acht gestern abend da
sorgte das thema corona für sehr
leidenschaftliche plädoyers immer mal
ein ich glaube wir müssen den
ungeimpften den weg zurück ebenen in die
gesellschaft aus der sie jetzt
weitgehend ausgeschlossen sind das heißt
sie müssen auch wieder restaurants und
cafés
sport clubs und theater betreten können
und und und das ist ja auch nicht allzu
schwierig in wahrheit denn wir erkennen
doch heute das mit omikron dass die
geimpften so ansteckend sind wie die
ungeimpften das kann man heute einfach
so pauschal sagen die geimpften schützen
sich nur selbst gegen schwere
krankheitsverläufe arbeit infektiös sind
sie auch ungeimpfte also zurück in den
handel das findet star cologne ist hans
ulrich jörges bräuchte es dafür aber
nicht zuverlässige test kapazitäten nur
eigentlich schon aber es herrscht eben
pcr-test mangel in deutschland immer
mehr positive corona test sie unsere
labor kapazität sprengen unser reporter
peter wickel der hat jetzt einen
pcr-test hersteller besuch der drei mal
schneller tests auswerten kann als
bislang
pcr tests weisen eine krone infektion
mit sicherheit nach doch jetzt möchte
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach nur
noch klinikpersonal und risikopatienten
bevorzugt mit diesen testen lassen der
grund die deutschen labore kommen weil
mit der auswertung nicht mehr hinterher
die auslastung beträgt schon 95 prozent
zwei jahre pandemie und schon wieder
herrscht warenmangel diesmal sind es die
pcr tests hier beim biotech unternehmen
qiagen in hilden meint man die lösung zu
haben wir schauen uns das heute mal
genauer an
das deutsche unternehmen produziert
sowohl pcr tests als auch maschinen für
die auswertung der tests
auch hier werden die tests in
ausreichender menge produziert aber in
deutschen laboren mangelt es an personal
und maschinen für die auswertung warum
ist das so in deutschland hat man sich
entschieden die frage eins bin ich ein
sicherer kontakt mit schnelltests
anzugehen und hat da entsprechend auch
kapazitäten aufgebaut und pcr tests
waren vorenthalten für eine bestätigung
eigentlich alles positiv schnelltests
oder aber auch für den diagnostik- wenn
man sich krank führt dadurch sind da ist
sehr viel weniger kapazitäten aufgebaut
worden deutschland hat zu lange auf den
weniger sicheren schnelltest gesetzt im
nachhinein fatal in der letzten woche
gab es mehr als eine million positive
pcr tests tendenz steigend die
laborkapazitäten durch neue maschinen
und neues personal schnell erhöhen in
der kurzen zeit nicht machbar die
vorhandenen kapazitäten müssen daher
effektiver genutzt werden
einen test haben wir bei medien
entwickelt der genau darauf abzielt im
prinzip die vorhandenen kapazitäten
besser zu verwenden es ist unser us pro
pfund im test der für die last auf zwei
tests verwendet wird und labore die auf
diese technologie umgestellt haben
schaffen durchaus ein faktor 3 mehr an
am tests haus zu berichten auf gleichen
equipment und gleichem personal dreimal
mehr kapazität durch eine drei mal
kürzere auswertung wie funktioniert das
also der ablauf im labor wird sehr stark
verkürzt und das haben wir durch eine
neue art der probenvorbereitung
realisieren können einem normalen pc
attest muss ich im prinzip dass man eine
probe waschen damit die pz aktion
durchgeführt werden kann dafür brauche
ich ein eigenes equipment und bei diesem
test haben wir jetzt eine flüssig phasen
extraktion gemacht sich alles mit dem
test zusammen auf einem equipment
durchführten ich heiße ich muss eine
maschine weniger beladen eine maschine
weniger entladen und habe einen sehr
schnellen arbeitsablauf also die
arbeitsabläufe im labor werden extrem
interessiert ist dieser neue test also
die lösung für das deutsche pcr-test
problem
eher unwahrscheinlich
die meisten labore nutzen noch die
herkömmlichen tests dazu dauert eine
umstellung auf den neuen test mindestens
vier wochen karl lauterbach rechnet aber
schon in zwei wochen mit dem höhepunkt
der uni konnte
trotzdem der hersteller setzt darauf
dass die laborkapazitäten auch für die
zeit nach omikron erhöht werden wir
hoffen dass die pandemie zu ende ist und
wir hoffen jedes mal dass die welle die
letzte rede ist sieht natur hat uns
immer wieder gezeigt so etwas in petto
insofern da ist schon auch ein wille der
politik gefragt ja wir wollen diese
kapazitäten haben und ja wir gehen auch
das risiko ein dass wir jetzt eventuell
die letzte welle haben und wenn man
etwas aufbauen lag kapazitäten schafft
die produktion in den werken helden
sowohl von alten als auch neuen test
läuft auf hochtouren das unternehmen
exportiert weltweit 18 millionen pcr
tests wohnen in der letzten woche hier
bei kia gen produziert und verpackt dort
hinten in dem abgeschotteten bereich
wird sogar mit corona positiven material
gearbeitet und das alles geschieht unter
strengsten sicherheitsvorkehrungen denn
am ende geht es hier nicht nur um die
produktionssicherheit des unternehmens
sondern um die sicherheit dass
deutschland mit pcr tests beliefert wird